hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich habe heute zwei anlässe
genutzt damit ich heute kleine mini
bürger machen kann und zwar wurde ich
einmal gefragt ob ich nicht etwas zu
fasching machen kann
deswegen habe ich gedacht so ein kleiner
mini burger das wäre doch was toll ist
für eine kleine faschingsfeier oder
einfach so fürs buffet und ich wurde
auch gefragt ob ich denn nicht mal was
für den super bowl machen kann der
selbst am ersten februar
was ist das super bowl eigentlich ist
das football oder internationales
fußballturnier und die ganze welt
schaute daraufhin footballer ja okay
weil das tut ja das weiß ich mit dem
oval das ist alles klar also football
geschaut das natürlich nett an aber ich
nutze natürlich als anlass um euch jetzt
kleine mini burger zu machen
ich werde jetzt mein hamburger brot
selber machen und zu halten ist einfach
so richtig schöne lockere kleine
brötchen und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten und später
zeigen wir euch die zutaten für innen
rein
also ich brauche jetzt 600 gramm mehl
200 milliliter milch einen halben würfel
hefe des um 20 gramm vier esslöffel
warmes wasser das ist jetzt lauwarm aber
hat darf nicht mehr als 30 grad haben
ein esslöffel zucker einen teelöffel
salz ich habe zwei eier die eidotter
also das eigelb brauche ich später zum
bestreichen und es geht mit in den teig
und später nämlich noch etwas sesam zum
bestreuen
ich werde den teig jetzt in der
küchenmaschine machen aber ihr könnt ihr
natürlich wie immer auch per hand
verkneten
und ich nehme jetzt einfach mal mein
wasser und zerbröselt die hefe hinein
damit die sich hier schon mal auflösen
kann
und da kommt der zucker noch mit dazu so
bekommt die hefe einfach ein bisschen
nahrung und kann eben besser aufgehen
ich lasse es jetzt vorher nicht aufgeben
könnte man es natürlich auch so fünf
minuten stehen lassen damit es so ein
bisschen schon mal aufgehen kann
aber ich mache das jetzt einfach direkt
in drei kunde aus den teig dann einfach
länger gehen
ich gebe mein komplettes mehl in eine
schüssel rein oder nee ich gebe jetzt
erst mal nur so so fast komplett rein
also 23 prozent
das sind schon so drei viertel lebt da
meine hefe mischung mit dazu tipps öl
vergesse ich gleich noch ab dann die
mädels ein salz und das eiweiß und lasst
es schon mal verrühren und hole mir
tut's mein olivenöl
jetzt nehme ich mein olivenöl und geht
es dann einfach mit in den teig 100
milliliter
und jetzt gebe ich hier nach und nach
einfach noch mehr mit dazu so dass
ebenen schöner teig entsteht der teig
wurde jetzt etwa fünf minuten verknetet
und jetzt nehme ich mir ein bisschen öl
in meiner hand und vertreibt es so ein
bisschen gibt es auch auf die
arbeitsfläche und hole mir den teig hier
raus einfach so mit den händen und ich
hatte da auf 30 grad eingestellt das
heißt der teig ist auch schon so ein
bisschen warm das heißt er fängt auch
nicht gleich an richtig schön aufzugehen
und jetzt vorm ich daraus einfach eine
schöne kugel und es sich auch so ein tag
da ist schön weich aber jetzt nicht zu
weich also der zerläuft ihr ziel nicht
mit decke ich den rundum mit dem öl
damit er einfach nicht austrocknet an
der oberfläche einstreichen
und ich gebe ihnen jetzt bei mir wieder
zurück in diese schüssel und lass ihn
einfach mal so etwa eine halbe stunde
bis stunde aufgehen ist dass sich
einfach etwa verdoppelt hat mein
hefeteig ist aufgegangen wenn man
deutlich sehen kann da war vorhin
richtig klein und jetzt so richtig groß
und ich nehme mir mein restliches mehl
und gibt es hier auf die arbeitsfläche
denn ich fahre jetzt zuerst mal meine
burger brote und während die dann
wackeln kümmere ich mich ebenso lang ums
fleisch richtig schöner weißer teig und
den teile ich jetzt in kleine portionen
ich nehme trotz dafür eine waage
ihr könnt es auch gern per augenmaß
machen aber ich will eben dass alle
bürger gleich groß werden und bei mir
haben jetzt alle 45 gramm sowie geht's
ab damit sie einfach nicht zu groß
werden
und wenn ihr die brötchen aufgeteilt
habt werden sie jetzt rund geformt also
wir müssen die brötchen schleifen heißt
es und zwar zeige durch das kurziel so
ein stückchen und vorwärts von außen
nach innen den teig damit der rand und
die oberfläche einfach schön glatt wird
und das brötchen einfach später auch
hübsch aussieht und dann nehmt ihr das
hier in die hand und könnt einfach mit
den händen also mit den fingern von
außen nach innen so kommt immer alles
von außen hier rein und die oberfläche
wird schon klappt und das nennt sie
schleifen setzt sich brötchen stecken
weil es war großartig gekümmert
anspreche wenn du dich mal vor der
kamera zeigt schon sein outfit zeigt
oder seht ihr das mit genauso
schaltet rennen mit den mit dem
charakter wahrscheinlich mache traurige
karen trend geht immer so sehen jetzt
meine brötchen aus ich habe übrigens 23
brötchen geformt und die denke ich jetzt
gleich noch mal mit einem geschirrtuch
ab und lass dir einfach noch mal eine
halbe stunde lang gehen und ihn derzeit
bereite ich schon mal meine soße und
mein fleisch born ich benutze jetzt für
meine burger ein gemischtes hackfleisch
das heißt ich habe jetzt rind und lamm
gemeinsam das hab ich jetzt in einem typ
bei einem türkischen messel gekauft und
ich nehme es jetzt ganz gern einfach
langsam besonderen geschmack hat wer
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr natürlich
auch nur rinder hackfleisch nehmen
aber ihr müsst einfach darauf achten
dass der fettgehalt stimmt das heißt bei
einem optimalen burger ist der
fettgehalt mindestens 20 prozent damit
einfach schön saftig wird und nicht
trocken wird das mal nicht ein maximal
40 prozent
denn wenn es über 40 prozent fettanteil
hat dann bricht der bürger später
auseinander also dabei bleibt nicht
zusammen und ich habe da jetzt einfach
ein kilo hackfleisch und es wird sich
jetzt mit pfeffer salz und ich nehme
ganz wenig kreuzkümmel einfach wegen
diesen lammfleisch und ich gebe es etwa
einen teelöffel salz dazu und eine gute
prise pfeffer
ich hab hier so'n kunden pfeffer den
hatte ich mir mal aus der türkei
mitgebracht aber ein schwarzer pfeffer
geht natürlich auch und ich nehme ihn
einfach ganz gern frisch gemahlen
weil das aroma viel besser und viel
intensiver ist richtig lecker fälle
burger
was manchen gästen bergermann ich
natürlich glaube ich nicht weil ich
glaube erst das sport schwammkopf weil
der krebs oder unter wasser
stimmt der kann sogar unter wasser grimm
hat schon durch die kelle widerspruch
mit 2k was sie empfangen mit dem
benutzer immer gleich ich ziehe
tanzschuhe an weil ich einfach das
fleisch zu zwölf verkneten will aber ihr
könnt es natürlich auch ganz einfach mit
den händen machen und es müssen wir
jetzt einfach so etwa 23 minuten lang
durchkneten
damit sich alles gut vermischt hat und
dann lassen sich diese bürger diese
partie einfach besser formen und jetzt
nehme ich mir immer so einen großen ball
mit fleisch also das 170 gramm bei mir
ich mache mini burger deswegen ist nicht
so viel und es einfach nur mal kurz
zusammen und ich habe zu hause keinen
per tv gibt die extra für hamburger oder
eben burger allgemeinen petty forma wo
man eben das fleisch formen kann
ihr könnt es jetzt entweder mit der hand
machen dass ihr das praktische zu flach
drückt und es einfach so ungefähr macht
oder ihr nehmt euch das ist mir
eingefallen das sieht nämlich so ähnlich
aus wie in petit forma ich habe hier zum
beispiel so ein dessert und habe hier
noch so ein stampfer dazu also damit
kann man vorspeisen oder auch desserts
machen und ich legte es jetzt einfach
hier rein und drückt mit diesem stampfer
rein dass es einfach richtig glatt wird
und vor allem gepresst wird
und so sieht es doch schon mal richtig
hübsch meine pattinson jetzt fertig und
teil habe ich schon im kühlschrank und
die gebe ich jetzt auch in den
kühlschrank bin ich muss jetzt erstmal
meine soße zubereiten und die müssen
einfach noch mal richtig kalt werden
dann kann man sie einfach später besser
beraten als sauce habe ich mir überlegt
eine kommune zu machen und dafür
brauchen wir eine avocado die ist jetzt
schon reif das heißt die avocado ist
außen schwarz und sehr weich eine
knoblauchzehe etwas zitronensaft salz
und pfeffer und ich zeige euch noch die
zutaten die wir später einfach nur für
die fertigstellung brauchen
ich habe hier noch bisschen butter das
sind etwa 25 bis 30 gramm etwas
paprikapulver ich habe zum scharfes ihr
könnt aber auch um süßes nehmen und
einfach zwei zwiebeln
wer möchte nimmt dann zwar noch ein paar
tomaten arbeitet noch immer später wenn
man den hamburger zusammensetzen jetzt
schneide ich die avocado in der mitte
durch es geht auch recht einfach weil es
einfach sehr weich ist und die hat im
innern so einen großen kern den brauchen
wir natürlich nicht und da sie so weit
ist kann ich jetzt einfach mit einem
löffel hergehen und dieses fruchtfleisch
herauskratzen einfach in der schale rein
und gorka mole kennt man ja so zum
beispiel von nachos da gibt man dir auch
ganz gerne rein und ich erst das total
gerne morgens als brotaufstrich ist
natürlich ein super stinken dort
startenden tag war einfach viel
knoblauch darin steckt aber ich finde es
einfach super lecker ich gebe da auch
manchmal gerne einfach ein paar
gewürfelte tomaten mit dazu wer den
kernstädten normalerweise immer wieder
mit dazu damit einfach weg guacamole
brown wird so ein trick oder wie er ein
fachmann in die blätter wieder dazu
stecken in sachen so und die zeit drücke
ich jetzt kurz mit einer gabel
das geht ganz einfach weil jetzt nämlich
die knoblauchzehe und schälen die und
hat sie auch einfach ganz klein in die
10 dazu
ich habe jetzt übrigens mit gedacht denn
ich wollte eigentlich meine
knoblauchzehen fein reiben und nicht
fein hacken
und weil ich jetzt keine lust habt da
gleich auf die knoblauch zuweisen werde
ich da einfach über das mit einem
pürierstab durchgehen das heißt wenn der
knoblauchpresse hat oder wenn er reibe
hat reibt einfach den dem flugloch ich
dich beim
jetzt gebe ich noch zitronensaft mit
dazu können danach geschmack machen ich
nehme etwa die halb zitrone und dann
kommt noch salz pfeffer rein und das
muss jetzt einfach nur noch kurz
verrührt werden und müsste das
abschmecken
wir können es einfach zur seite stellen
meine brötchen sind inzwischen schon
aufgegangen
und ich werde jetzt noch mit dem eigelb
bestreichen da habe ich jetzt einfach
nur ein esslöffel wasser dazu gegeben
damit bislang flüssiger wird einfach
kurz berühren und dann streiche ich
dieses eiweiß einfach elf einfach auf
die brötchen drauf ist richtig schön
rund und jetzt gebe ich dann noch den
see samt rüber und danach werden die
brötchen einfach bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr 20 bis 25
minuten gebacken bis sie schön goldbraun
sind und jetzt muss ich noch meine
zwiebel fein hacken bzw ich schneide
einfach in feine ringe und die werde ich
jetzt gleich in butter und etwas
olivenöl einfach so müssen anbraten
jetzt habe ich hier etwas öl in der
pfanne das sind etwa drei esslöffel und
gibt einfach ein kleines stück butter
dazu und sobald sie in butter
geschmolzen ist dies hat für den
geschmack ist zuständig auch olivenöl
ist gebe ich einfach noch die
zwiebelringe mit dazu und lasse einfach
kurz braten
und jetzt nehme ich die zwiebeln einfach
raus auch die kleinen stücke damit jetzt
nicht noch vier rennen und in die
gleiche pfanne lege ich jetzt die partie
frei damit die jetzt einfach von beiden
seiten richtig schön angebraten werden
ich habe jetzt alles ziemlich
gleichzeitig vorbereitet und ich muss
jetzt nur noch meine brötchen
aufschneiden und steht dann noch kurz
anbraten
das finde ich dann einfach wissen
leckerer müsste arbeitstechnik machen
und die lassen sich am besten mit so
einem brotmesser schneiden und ich nehme
jetzt einfach wieder die gleiche pfanne
schöpfer aber jetzt ist erst mal raus
denn ich möchte da jetzt gleich nur den
buttergeschmack drin haben aber ihr
müsst jetzt nicht aufs waschen
jetzt gebe ich die butter einfach da
rein den rest und verlasse die hier in
der pfanne und sobald sie geschmolzen
ist gebe ich dann noch mein
paprikapulver mehr dazu
jetzt bekommt die mutter eben das aroma
von der paprika wird noch ein bisschen
mit gebraten und es riecht einfach
richtig lecker scheint auch so ein
bisschen auf und jetzt kann ich die
brötchen darin mit der schweiz seite so
ein bisschen noch anbraten
jetzt gebe ich noch wissel salz über
meine zwiebeln drüber damit die einfach
zum eigenen geschmack bekommen hat so
ein bisschen und ich nehme jetzt noch
ein bisschen sind nicht zu viel denn ich
möchte dass die kommune so den meisten
geschmack hat und gibt infiziert so ein
bisschen auf das brötchen einfach auf
unterseite oder sitz richtig klasse
ausschließlich 100
jetzt gebe ich meine zwiebeln 2 strafe
ich habe die ganze geschichte aber
geschichte ist einfach mal so sagte
weiter familiengericht eigentlich nicht
so eine geschmack in meinem kopf und ich
hoffe das schmeckt so wie ich ihn mir
ausgedacht habe ich meine wer hat schon
mal einen burger mit guacamole gegessen
vor allen dingen mit lammfleisch sich
auch die gabe ich habe auch nicht warum
ich mir schmeckt alles irgendwie passt
alles es gebe ich meinen kleinen strauß
dann dekor kamolow mein gott ist darf
ich probieren oder gleich die spiele
schon wie das wasser im mund zusammen
contact manager magazin jetzt fertig und
ich muss sagen die sehen genauso aus wie
ich sie mir vorgestellt hatte
jetzt hoffe ich natürlich sie schmecken
hinaus sehe ich mir einfach ein messer
und halbierte mal war murat ja auch
probiert
probiert immer ich es richtig lustig
zuvor
das rezept für die leckeren burger gibt
es natürlich auf meinem blog auf
cellestis blog.de vielen dank ich jetzt
vielleicht lernt und ich wünsche euch
auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
falls ihr lust habt diese bürger auch
nach zu machen oder abzuwandeln können
das natürlich auch machen aber ich bin
grad mit guacamole ist das ein richtig
leckere burger vor allen dingen mit
diesem lamm hackfleisch ich will auf
diesen curry gibt es auch super karibik
war auch so ich denke man nächste woche
einfach noch so ein saucen spezial wobei
euch noch so drei saucen vorstellen die
ihr auch zb für den bürger benutzen
könnt ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen bis
zum nächsten mal